اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام كلما تعمقنا
اكثر في الملف اليمني اكتشف المزيد عن
الدور الاماراتي ابعاده وادواته رجاله
واهدافه نسلط الضوء الليله على محافظه
المهره هي منطقه تقع على حدود عمان وتسيطر
فيها الامارات تقريبا على كل شيء جندت
الالاف في معسكرات تابعه لها وانفقت
الكثير من المال لشراء ذمم البعض وولائهم
في محطه الحصاد الثالثه نتابع ما الذي
يحدث في المهره اماراتيا ولماذا وما هي
الخطط المستقبليه تقرير محمد
ر تعد المهره بوابه اليمن الشرقيه وتقع
على حدود سلطنه عمان وتمتد على مساحه
واسعه باعتبارها ثانيه اكبر المحافظات بعد
حضرموت ومساحتها تساوي مساحه الامارات
وتمتاز بمناطق سياحيه خلابه ولها منفذان
صفت وشحن تندرج المهره عسكريا ضمن قياده
المنطقه الثانيه وقد ظلت بعيده عن الحرب
الدائره في اليمن غير ان انظار السلطات
الاماراتيه اتجهت صوبها نشاط عسكري متسارع
وهو امر استفز اهلها خدمات الهلال الاحمر
الاماراتي في اليمن كانت الغطاء الذي
انطلقت تحته الامارات في المهره ثم تحركت
عسكريا وامنيا بانشاء وحدات مسلحه لها ثم
وقفت ابو ظبي بعدها وراء تعيين شخصيه من
المهره تقيم في الامارات هو محمد احمد
قحطان المجيبه المشهور بقحطان المجيبه في
منصب مدير امن المحافظه وكان هذا الرجل
على صله وثيقه بيوسف سعيد الكعبي من
الهلال الاحمر الاماراتي وهو ما يشير الى
ان الكعبي لم يكن دوره اغاثي فقط وبعد
تزايد نفوذهم طلب الاماراتيين كشوفا
وخرائط لمواقع قوات الجيش والامن فاذ عنت
القوات للضغوط الاماراتيه بعد تهديد بوقف
المساعدات ورواتب الجنود وفي الاشهر
الاولى من وجودها في المهره وزعت الامارات
نحو 30 سياره لاستقطاب الوجهاء واختارت
الشيخ العو ثاني الذي يحمل الجنسيه
الاماراتيه ليكون واجهه لتحركاتها وواصلت
الامارات خطواتها في التوسع فباشر في فتح
معسكر تدريب لها وكانت الخطه ان يتم تجنيد
2000 من شباب المهره في معسكرات تابعه
للامارات او مواليه لها ثم لاجات بعدها
الى التجنيد القائم على اساس قبلي لضمان
مزيد من الولاء مستغله علاقاتها ببعض شيوخ
القبائل وكان الرد العماني اتجاه التحرك
الاماراتيه بزياده حجم المساعدات لمحافظه
المهره التي تربطها علاقات قويه مع سلطنه
عمان وقد اضطرت الامارات الى تغيير طاقمها
العامل بالمهره عقب ردود فعل غاضبه اتجاه
دفعه تجنيد قامت بها على اساس قبلي وفي
خطوه مفاجئه طلب الاماراتي ان يكون افراد
القوات التي تم تجنيدها بدعم منهم تحت
اشرافهم وقبيل شهر رمضان الفائت طلب
الاماراتي من جميع افراد القوات البالغ
عددهم 1600 جندي دربتهم الامارات العوده
الى معسكر الخالديه للتدريب لكن مصادر في
الاداره المحليه للمهره اشارت الى ان عدد
من حضروا كان
332 جنديا فقط وزعوا على مديريات المهره
ويخضعون لاداره واشراف القوات الاماراتيه
في الاسابيع الاخيره غير الاماراتيين
لهجتهم مع السلطات المحليه وشيوخ القبائل
لتصبح اكثر شده معتبرين انهم يمثلون قوات
التحالف العربي لتبدا بذلك مشادات بينهم
وبين ابناء قبيله سمودا حيث يقع معسكر
الخالديه الذي تتحرك منه القوات
الاماراتيه ضمن اراضيها اما الوجود
العسكري في المحافظه فمعدل لكن قبل فتره
قصيره زار وفد سعودي المعسكرات والمواقع
الحيويه في المهره بمعيه المحافظ وضابط
اماراتي يدعى ابو فارس زعماء شايخ المهره
الذين تربطهم علاقات بسلطنه عمان لا
يرغبون في الوجود الاماراتي على اراضيهم
كما ان محافظ المهره الشيخ محمد عبد الله
كدا رفض بشده الانضمام الى المجلس
الانتقالي الذي تدعمه
الامارات لمناقشه هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من اسطنبول ياسين التميمي الكاتب والمحلل
السياسي اليمني ومن لندن صالح الجبواني
المحلل السياسي اليمني ارحب بكما وابدا
معك ك سيد ياسين التميمي في ضوء ما ورد في
التقرير ما سر اهتمام الامارات
بالمهره بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم تحيه لك
ولضيفك الكريم ولمشاهده قناه الجزيره
الامارات تتصرف للاسف الشديد كدوله احتلال
وانا اعتقد ان هذا السلوك في محافظه
المهره مؤشر كبير على ان هذا السلوك هو
سلوك احتلال في المقام الاول لان محافظه
المهره اصلا هي بعيده عن العمليات
العسكريه وبعيده عن اطراف الصراع وبالتالي
كان يجب عن على محافظه المهره ان تكون في
كنف السلطه الشرعيه ولكن هذا لا لم يتم
ابدا بل بالعكس يعني خلال او قبل سنه
تقريبا او اقل من سنه تقريبا سربت اخبار
عن تهريب اسلحه عبر سلطنه عمان وكان واضح
وصدق الكثيرون ونحن منهم هذه المقوله وكان
الهدف هو شيطنه ربما سلطنه عمان من اجل
تمكين او مزيد من التمكين العسكري والامني
ل او ممارسه الابتزاز للجانب العماني لكي
ترسخ الامارات اقدامها في محافظه المهره ا
في الوقت الذي يحتاج اليمنيون فيه التسريع
في انهاء
الانقلاب تكرس الامارات للاسف يعني معظم
جهودها لفرض نفوذها كما يحدث في المهره
وكما يحدث في سقطره و هناك تواجد
للانقلابيين على سبيل المثال في شبوه وهي
محافظه
مجاوره لحضرموت ومع ذلك للاسف الشديد لا
يبدل التحالف العربي الجهد الكافي
لاخراجهم من هذه من تلك المحافظه لان من
الواضح ان خط تهريب الاسلحه الذي يبدا من
المهره وينتهي في شبوه لازال نشط للغايه
وهذا وهذا الخط ربما يستفاد الى حد كبير
من خبرات المخلوع صالح لان هذا الخط قبل
وصفت الوضع بالظهره بانه سلوك سلوك
احتلالي هنا انتقل الى السيد صالح
الجبواني اسمح لي كيف يمكن توصيف الوضع او
الوجود الاماراتي في المهره هل هو فعلا
سلوك احتلال كما يقول السيد تميمي ام ان
الموضوع يذهب الى ابعد من
ذلك هو الامارات العربيه المتحده وسلوكها
في المهره يرقى الى الوصايه والاحتلال
ذلك ان هذا السلوك يثبت انه كل ما نقوله
عن الامارات منذ بدايه هذه الحرب هو صحيح
ذلك ان الامارات تشتغل خارج اهداف عاصفه
الحزم في اسقاط الانقلاب واستعاده الدوله
الامارات الى جانب سيطرتها الكامله على
محافظه المهره تريد احتواء المملكه
العربيه السعوديه من الجنوب من المهره الى
باب المندب ثم اغلاق البوابه الشرقيه عمان
ربما الامارات العربيه المتحده ليس وحدها
في هذا المسعى ولكن ربما تقف خلفها قوى
اخرى لا نعلم عنها شيئا وفي لحظه ما ربما
المملكه العربيه السعوديه وعمان تقول ريت
اللي جرى ما كان لان الامارات العربيه
المتحده وبالخصوص ابو ظبي تشتغل تحت رايه
التحالف العربي
وكل ما تعمله باسم هذا التحالف ف
يعطي لها نوع من الشرعيه في التحرك في هذه
المناطق كما قال الاستاذ ياسين المهره لم
تكن دار حرب ولم يصلها الحوثيين ولا قوات
صالح المهره لم تصلها داعش ولا القاعده
اذا ماذا تحتاج المهره المهره تحتاج الى
المحروقات تحتاج الى التموين لا تحتاج الى
فتح هذه المعسكرات كلها لا تحتاج الى هذا
الضخ الكبير للاموال
وللسيارات المساعدات المختلفه للمشايخ هنا
نتسا اين هي المملكه العربيه السعوديه وهي
قائده للتحالف العربي في اليمن سيد تميمي
عن المشهد تحديدا في
المهره من الواضح ان المملكه العربيه
السعوديه مغيبه تماما على المحافظات
الجنوبيه وان هناك نوع من التخد الخفي جدا
يعني هناك يد مطلقه للامارات العربيه
المتحده للتصرف كما يحلو لها في الا في
المحافظات الجنوبيه ولتمرير ربما مشروع
مستقبلي وهو تفكيك اليمن وتقسيمه وتجزئه
وهذه مشكله لا تزال قائمه ح حتى هذه
اللحظه نحتاج الى ادله كافيه للتاكد من ان
الرياض فعلا اعطت تفويض للامارات لتصرف
على هذا النحو لانه اذا لم تكن قد اعطت
هذا التفويض للامارات العربيه المتحده فان
ما يجري الان يمس بشكل واضح ومباشر
المصالح الحيويه للمملكه العربيه السعوديه
التي ترتبط ارتباطا وثيقا بامن واستقرار
اليمن وبالتالي هنا يجب الانتقال فورا الى
المرجعيات السياسيه للحل ويجب ان يكون
تصرف وسلوك التحالف العربي في اليمن مبني
على المرجعيه الثلاث التدخل العسكري
للتحالف العربي جاء بناء على طلب الرئيس
والسه
الشعيه
الشيه يفرض نفوذ النفوذ الاماراتي في
المهره هو مقلق لهذه الدرجه
مقلق هو هو يمارس مهمتين خطيرتين جدا اولا
تفكيك اليمن من خلال فرض نفوذ على
المحافظات الجنوبيه وايضا فرض ممارسه
احتواء لسلطنه عمان و الحاق الاذى بسلطنه
عمان وهي مهمه بدات منذ 2011 يعني معروف
ان العلاقات الاماراتيه العمانيه ليست
جيده وبالتالي هناك حرص على ان على محاصره
عمان من هذه الزاويه على وجه التحديد على
الرغم من ان سلطنه عمان
طيله العقود الماضيه استطاعت ان تقيم
علاقه ربما سويه مع جارتها على الرغم من
خصوصيه العلاقه الاجتماعيه التي تربط بين
سكان غرب عمان و
سكان المهره القعه الى الشرق من الجوريه
الى دور دور القبائل في
هذه اساسا للوجود الاماراتي الى اي مدى
يمكن ان يؤثر على تمدد النفوذ الاماراتي
سيد جبوي في منطقه
المهره نعم القبائل هي تشكل معظم السكان
في محافظه المهره ولذلك الامارات العربيه
المتحده استهدفت الشخصيه الرئيسيه في
محافظه المهره وهو السلطان عبد الله بن
عيسى بن عفرار
ودفعت به الى ما يسمى بالمجلس الانتقالي
الجنوبي ذلك ان الامارات اول ما تفعل في
المناطق التي اتت اليها تاتي بالاشخاص
والاتباع الذين يؤيدونه ويسيرون في في
فلكها تاتي بهم اما الى الكيانات الموازيه
التي انشاتها في المحافظات الجنوبيه
كالمجلس الانتقالي او تاتي بهم قاده
عسكريين في الوحدات الامنيه والعسكريه
التي انشاتها مثل الحزام الامني ومثل
النخبه الحضرميه
ومثل اداره الامن في المهره التي اتت
بمدير الامن وهو مقيم في الامارات العربيه
المتحده ثم حينما تضمن هؤلاء الناس تبدا
تتصرف
كدوله لها اليد الاولى والطوله في هذه
المناطق طبعا محافظه المهره فيها تعدد
قبلي لم يكن يسمح للامارات كما ذكرت
التقرير بان تكون الكلمه الاولى والاخيره
للشيخ السلطان بن عفرار بعد ان علمت هذه
القبائل ان سلوك الامارات في المهره ليس
سلوكا للدعم والمسانده ولكن له اهداف اخرى
ثم ان
هذا السلوك الاماراتي يؤثر على العلاقه
التاريخيه بين القبائل في المهره والقبائل
في اقليم
ظفار داخل عمان وهذه منطقه متداخله فيها
مصالح متداخله فيها مصاهره فيها انساب
القبائل ذات جذور واحده
لذلك هذه القبائل اتخذت موقف لكن اذا لم
تتحرك المملكه العربيه السعوديه عمل
الاحتواء الدور الاماراتي في غيرها من
محافظات الجنوب اليمني فان فان الو الوضع
سيؤول برمته الى الا ش شكرا لك من لندن
صالح الجبواني المحلل السياسي اليمني عذرا
على قاطعه بسبب ضيق الوقت من اسطنبول
ياسين التميمي الكاتب والمحلل السياسي
اليمني ايضا شكرا لك شكرا لكم مشاهدينا
والى
[موسيقى]
اللقاء